if it's a mountain lion do not turn in
rod because that signals the felines
instincts to go and get you hi my name
is Christopher Naresh I'm a survival
educator and today I'm going to show you
the top five tips for how to survive in
the woods so when you get to a spot in
the woods the first thing you want to do
is have some kind of a shelter and if
you didn't bring something with you I
would look for something in the woods
that's ready to occupy natural shelters
might be actual caves might be thickets
of grass and leaves man-made shelters
might be shacks old cars I even slept in
an outhouse once one time in the Sequoia
I burrowed into a thicket of pine
needles on a hillside just burrowed in
like a hole slept there snug all night
so the second thing you want to do when
you're in the woods is determine your
food source now the two sources of food
that you're going to find in the woods
are plants and animals plants are easier
because they don't run away from you but
you need to study them you need to you
can't just randomly eat things and think
you're gonna survive for example all
acorns can be eaten seaweeds if you're
near the coast they can all be eaten
assuming you're not in a polluted area
wild onions which are common throughout
the country all cacti are edible
assuming they're palatable even the
green algea then the pond scum you could
eat now in terms of animals literally
anything can be eaten the easiest thing
would be insects I've taken walking
sticks swatted grasshoppers as they went
away from me take off the head take off
the wings take off the legs and sautee
them and you have a delicious meal any
larvae can be eaten and any birds
lizards snakes rodents any of those
small things can be eaten if you have a
means to capture them for example
slingshots swallowed arrows sticks where
you stab them when it comes to bigger
animals it's gonna take a little bit of
skill because they're not living their
life to feed you and by the way do not
take killing an animal lightly it's a
serious matter don't do it for fun
you're gonna kill something eat the
animal tip number three water water is
really important now if I'm going into
an area I'm gonna do a little bit of
research to make sure there's water
there in the first place I don't like to
go into areas where there's no water
I've done that it's miserable so you
want to have water there in the form of
extreme rivers lakes if there's no water
around you could eat cactus you could
dig wells in dry stream beds I've done
that you dig deep enough where water has
flowed and you can get to the water you
could also take a large plastic bag tie
it onto a non-toxic tree like willow the
water in the leaf evaporates out it's
captured in the bag in the course of
several hours half a cup of water when
you find your water the big issue is is
it pure is it safe to drink there is no
way to simply look at the water and
determine that it's safe to drink the
water could be flowing and look pure and
and be unsafe the water could be
stagnant with insects in it and be safe
I would assume that some kind of
purification process should be done and
the universal way to purify water is
boiling you put it in your can to find a
beer can or a coke can and boil the
water boiling kills all of the
biological contaminants our next tip has
to do with fire fire is essential it's
not only warmth it's not only comfort
but it purifies your water it cooks your
food it helps you make tools it helps
you dry your clothes when you're wet the
ability to make a fire can mean the
difference between life and death
so there are four principles for making
fire there's friction there's
electricity there's the Sun and there's
chemicals most people are going to be
using friction or a combination of
friction and electricity
besides the bic lighter i would
recommend the magnesium fire starter
where you powder a little bit of
magnesium and you scrape an artificial
flint known as a ferrocerium rod get a
spark and you get a fire let's say
you're in the woods with your vehicle
you have a cigarette lighter you also
have the car battery you can stretch
steel wool from pole to pole or you put
the jumper cables on you touch some kind
of tinder together I usually stretch a
wire from one of the copper terminals
wrap it with some tinder touch the other
copper terminal and Bing
you have fire okay here's my fifth and
final tip how to survive a bear attack
first off in California the native
grizzly was pretty much killed off 100
years ago in Southern California so if
you're down in the south
you're not gonna see any Griz if a Griz
comes after you in Alaska or somewhere
awesome in the in the country I hope you
have your will in order because you
can't outrun a grizzly bear they're fast
you're probably a goner okay if it's a
black bear in the south and most of the
ones in the south were the bad bears but
they got rid of and they dumped in the
Angeles forest and down here further
south if it's one of those there was one
death in the last hundred years so if
you do encounter a bear in the woods and
there's a sufficient distance you know
make some make some noise you don't have
to do a big fuss but you want it to have
an exit so it can get away from you and
it will you scream make yourself big you
know do this but don't back off sorry oh
no did I break something okay so if it's
a mountain line do not turn and run
whatever you do because the felines
instinct is to go after you you make
noise
but don't turn and run just face it back
off back off give it room to escape and
hopefully you'll survive another day
this has been Christopher nargis with
your 5 tips to survive in the woods
did I break something costing you guys
money
[Music]